we lives in a pineapple under the sea
SpongeBob SquarePants
all right guys they got the spongebob
movie
sponge on the run I'm excited to check
this out this trailer is coming out
almost the one-year anniversary of the
creator Stephen Hillenburg unfortunate
passing I just say let's enjoy this
trailer in honor of his memory and his
legacy that he has created so yeah let's
do this guys I'm excited to check this
out John introduced me and I think a
whole bunch of other people the
spongebob was really adopted in great
early great school Oh No
for Gary I'll do paddy wagon just when I
thought we couldn't get more Keanu this
dance continues
[Music]
whoa
[Laughter]
tag save Gary well it's definitely
spongebob it's definitely got the whole
spirit the personality is the boy same
voice actors and everything designed the
sense yeah and so you know nothing
really to complain about here so many
Easter eggs however I know that Sponge
Bob sponge at of water you know what's
funny about this movie franchise the
movie specifically is that a lot of the
times when you take a show and then you
try to make movies out of it they are
often not well received or not good but
the movies have been you know like the
development to so far this being the
third one I've been doing pretty well
like box-office wise and what critics as
well I love the first movie I find it
funny how in the second one they did the
3d animation and then but it was all in
the real world and then here this is all
3d animation with like some real world
like Keanu means man the Keanu saw just
keeps it coming we gotta bring it into
the poem like for me personally for me
person you kind of slow down yeah yeah I
want to get sick of it I don't get two
minute Timothy Keanu memes going on but
also has one specific look that he's
always locked into now with straggly
beard and shoulder-length hair just wait
so Bill and Ted it's shaved I think this
looks very vibrant and energetic and a
lot of fun it feels like pure spongebob
but one you are a much bigger spongebob
fanatic than myself what did you think
of the trailer does the animation bother
you throwing the mic to you no I mean it
looks like a lot of fun and it looks
like spongebob yeah you know I mean it
looks like a bunch of loosely related
hijinks that are going to somehow tie
into getting Gary back fun by me I mean
you know I was watching this and I
appreciate that in doing the 3d
animation style they've also gone with a
stop-motion esque
yes just like motion quality in general
she looks a little more handmade even
though it's not I had to like kind of
second-guess it in the beginning of it
think it was this like claymation at
first yeah they've done claymation
specials and stuff in the in the past
that were actually claymation so I like
that they've kept that in the DNA
especially like and the first movie was
a hand-drawn or mostly hand-drawn movie
which I do miss but yeah if we're gonna
keep on you know doing spongebob I like
that each movie has had a semi different
visual palette to work with and yeah I
don't know I mean I was just flashing
back to the show I mean this has all the
different little like little elements
that I love which are just like the
crazy faces and the physical comedy gags
and the things that are adapted for
nautical life or whatever I have a new
paddy wagon which you know there's
always some kind of thing yeah burger
related Krusty Krab mobile or something
like that that's how much Squidward in
here
there's no Squidward in this trailer it
was like one mom house but you mean he
says no to when he's asking is anyone
seen Gary but that was the lack of
Squidward yeah I know which is usually
pretty surprising to me because I like
the characters I always like that I
think the three predominant characters
there's a lot of famous characters here
spongebob Patrick it's good work yeah
you got Sandy's voice for like a hot
second I wonder if maybe Squidward will
be at like the beginning her and when
they are you know still in bikini bottom
if they're when they give you Feb Adeem
ah joke no what were they making have
any much of it because in Avengers
infinity war he calls him Squidward
oh that's right baby hurry yeah take
nerd that's right
fake Bikaner I forgot a one joke joke
and they might yeah I'm sure somebody in
the spongebob audience will be like
ebony ma ha ha that reference whoo
you know I don't know I hope so I hope
it's filled with Avengers references I
hope this is the most referential meme
tacular product placement spongebob you
know I also find interesting is the
scooby-doo trailer came out this week
yes it's a completely different company
and then paramount which is thriving
right now yeah
he's come up with this trailer they both
have an element of origin to it the main
character meets their best bug yeah and
I'm wondering about that see I don't
know if camp coral is already out or if
it's gonna spin out of this movie yeah I
wonder which is a spinoff that is about
yeah it's about little spongebob and
meeting Gary as kids and stuff like that
it's we got to form
people in case they don't know John I
thought I said prequel series but yeah
I'm a little curious as to how that's
gonna work just because spongebob has
been on for so long I'm curious as to
what different they can do by making a
spongebob younger other than pitching it
towards younger guys you know cuz this
bunch Rob's already pretty kid
accessible and I'm sure has run through
a gamut of high jinks yeah alright guys
well what did you think of this
spongebob trailer do you enjoy it leave
a comment below you guys can subscribe
to the reel rejects please click that
notification well again notify would
never got a YouTube video up you can
check us out on the start us app over
there with your thirty second reaction
reviews for any film TV show and/or
trailer we post daily over there it's a
great app plenty of people use it
completely free to download it use it do
its day and last but not least all its
ends with a patron today shout out to a
lovely woman named Jenna
Randolph Jenna Jenna who lives in a
pineapple under the sea Jenna I hope you
have a happy Thanksgiving this year and
I hope you have a wonderful Merry
Christmas I know times can be up and
down this time of year for people like
you and I however I know you are
strongly family-oriented so you have a
great holiday season with your family
this year you stay classy and you stay
in touch with us at all costs and last
but not least make sure you kill a good
turkey for Thanksgiving and don't
forgive forget to give thanks to Keanu
because we all owe him what it worked
better if you didn't stumble there I
know didn't stump I know let's take it
again nope no no retakes here